logitech's gpro might just be the most
popular gaming mouse ever created
everyone knows that it is a high quality
head clicker used by some of the biggest
names in Esports and it's been that way
since the day it came out unfortunately
there has always been one glaring issue
with the g-pro and now super light most
people simply aren't ready to spend a
hundred and fifty dollars on a mouse
luckily we now have plenty of other
options some are cheap reliable mice
others are the pricey QA riddled
nightmares but when it comes to price to
Performance ratios there aren't many
companies that can beat Pulsar the X2
and X2 mini are some of the best mice on
the market right now and they're cheaper
than almost anything of similar quality
many people even consider the X2 good
enough to rival the G Pro and the super
light but is the X2 actually better
foreign
[Applause]
okay guys before we dive into the video
I will ever so quickly chill our merch
we've got tons of comfy t-shirts and
hoodies in lots of colors be sure to
check them out over on our page at
thescore.com to get your own okay so
many of you may have not even heard of
Pulsar until right now and that's fair
because all things considered they
haven't actually been around for very
long Pulsar is a South Korean company
that released their first gaming
peripherals back in 2020. they made a
big name for themselves with affordable
hot swappable and in some cases even
waterproof gaming keyboards but the
thing that really put Pulsar on the map
was their x-light gaming mouse it was
the company's first foray into the mouse
space an ergonomic lightweight Mouse
with a solid sensor the sensor is good
the the shape uh the shape's nice it was
pretty light I remember too it just
seemed like a wireless super light EC
but what really caught everyone's eye
wasn't the shape the initial X light was
only 50 US dollars and even when they
released newer Wireless versions Pulsar
managed to keep the price extremely
reasonable I do want to say though that
this mouse is actually very incredible
for 74.99 the price point really cannot
be beat and I do want to throw that out
there out of the gate because this thing
is really a beast for 74.99 for 80 this
is a very solid Wireless Ergo shape if
you want something that's light pretty
affordable and well performing and you
don't mind this a relatively just
generic Ergo shape then I would say go
for it ever since pulsar's peripherals
first hit the market back in 2020 their
motto has always been affordable
Innovation and as more and more people
got their hands on pulsar's keyboards
and X lights it became clear that they
had achieved exactly that but there was
still one thing missing from pulsar's
Mouse lineup they didn't have an
ambidextrous option as of late the
Logitech G Pro and more recently the
super light have been King when it comes
to ambidextrous gaming mice they're
lightweight Wireless have an incredible
sensor and most importantly logitech's
hallowed logo on them but it is
precisely the power behind that name
that has made these mice pretty darn
expensive a brand new super light will
leave a 160 dollar hole in your pocket
it's a price that your favorite pros and
content creators will pay no problem but
for a lot of us that is just way too
much thankfully Pulsar knew what Gamers
wanted and in August of last year
released their first ambidextrous mice
the X2 and X2 mini quickly made waves
within the peripheral space many people
praised them for their quality and of
course the extremely reasonable price I
think overall build quality is great the
same sensor you know they use all the
top of the line specs um daily so you
know like whatever the best sensors at
the moment they put it on their mice I
do gotta mention I think what I like the
most about them is price they keep all
that stuff under 100 bucks and that's
like it's big they could easily say 130
for it and people still pay 130 you know
because it has top of the line specs but
I think them keeping it at 90 or you
know 99 whatever it's at it's it's great
some tech reviewers even went so far as
to suggest that pulsar's new mice might
be better than the super light but did
Pulsar actually beat logy when it came
to their first Ambi mice well we decided
to find out for ourselves our sweet
lovely valorant lover Nile managed to
get his hands on both an X2 and an X2
mini and here's what he had to say and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about alright so before I get
into my review of the X2 and X2 mini I
just want to say a huge thank you to
lethal gaming gear for sending me both
mice to test out I really appreciate it
so make sure to go check him out now
this video isn't sponsored by Pulsar so
everything that I'm about to say is just
my honest unfiltered opinion but before
I get into my practical review let's
talk about the specs the Pulsar X2
Wireless is a 56 gram ambidextrous
gaming mouse with up to 70 hours of
battery life it's a similar shape and
size to the super light with a slightly
lower hum I've heard some people say
that the shape is similar to the xm1 and
zowie za13 but I don't own those mice so
I can't really say for sure what I do
know is that even when I compare it to
my 10 Starlight Pro which is a pretty
flat mouse the hump on the X2 is even
lower the bottom of the mouse has these
big cutouts which help reduce its weight
to only 56 grams and Pulsar even paints
their pcbs so they match the color of
each Mouse the DPI and power buttons are
also located on the bottom both mice use
a pixart 3395 sensor and as for the
switches the X2 and X2 mini both use
klgm 8.0 switches which feel nice and
light and here's how they sound
I didn't notice any pre or post travel
on the side buttons and the scroll wheel
feels high quality as well the stock
skates are honestly better than what you
get from most other brands out of the
box in my opinion although I've mainly
been using a control pad lately I think
the x2s will perform well on just about
any surface so who exactly is this mouse
designed for well if you have medium to
large sized hands then the X2 medium
that I have here will be a good option
for you whether you use a fingertip grip
or more of a claw grip this mouse should
work for most people if you have smaller
hands then I definitely recommend
checking out the X2 mini though it's a
bit too small for my liking but it has
the same internals as the X2 and
performs just as well alright now let's
get into my actual review I started off
by testing the X2 on my extra soft
Artisan hen pad and hopping on valorant
now since the Pulsar is only 56 grams
and both my DeathAdder V3 Pro and super
light weigh in at roughly 63 grams I
knew that the X2 wouldn't feel exactly
the same out of the box so to compensate
I lowered my sense by roughly nine
percent in game which helped a bit but I
still felt like I didn't have quite
enough control if you remember my review
of the 10 Starlight Pro a few months
back then you'll remember that I had a
similar problem with that Mouse since
then I've been looking for a slower
control pad and luckily I finally
managed to get my hands on the one that
I wanted after unboxing a fresh Artisan
zero I resume my testing and within a
few days I felt much more comfortable
with my aim on the X2 I was once again
fragging out like I was used to with my
other mice three two
oh no
foreign
the X2 works great for FPS games since
the new valorian episode dropped I've
been genuinely excited to play the game
again and so far I've loved my time with
this mouse but I've also been using the
X2 for other stuff these past few weeks
like raiding on old school RuneScape and
it still didn't disappoint and that's
pretty important for a RuneScape d-gen
like myself pulsar's software is also
straightforward and easy to use you can
even adjust the debounce delay although
I personally didn't have any double
clicking issues if you're looking for a
cheap Wireless ambidextrous Mouse with
solid internals then I would easily
recommend the Pulsar X2 and X2 mini if
you haven't already spent the money on a
super light then just buy this and if
you're someone who maybe bought the
original G Pro and you're debating
whether or not to upgrade to a super
light then I'd still recommend the X2
the shape doesn't feel exactly the same
but it's familiar enough that it won't
take long for you to get used to overall
I think Pulsar killed it even stuff like
the cables the adapter and especially
the packaging just looking incredible
and at 100 bucks U.S for all the premium
internals the price really can't be beat
so if you're in the market for a new
mouse then maybe it's time to check out
pulsar's offerings and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about so it seems like Pulsar really did
come through with the so-called
affordable Innovation their mice perform
just as well if not better than their
pricier competitors when we first
started you know like with mice and
stuff you always had to pay the 150
premium right like for the best stuff
right if you wanted like the best which
at the moment was like by racer and
Logitech you gotta be ready to spend 160
after tax and also I think whoever's
coming new to the Hobby for 100 bucks
now they're they can get a good bang for
their buck and Pulsar continues to step
their game up they've released a bunch
of new color options and the latest
iteration of the X2 features Optical
switches and zero d-bounce delay and
honestly this limited edition Bruce Lee
model looks incredible Pulsar has a hell
of a lot planned for 2023 new versions
of the X light the X2 new keyboards and
even a new es series mouse that features
OLED displays on the bottom and if the
quality and price is anything like what
Pulsar has already shown us
then I think we got a lot to be excited
about
I'm really excited for this uh I think
it's the x2h I've been using a zowie
Zeta for literally years and years and
years and I've never switched off the
mouse ever I am enticed I'm tempted by
pulsar's new Option this could be the
zowie killer for me it's possible we'll
see